listen the album uh the album is out
right now
um you have a crazy obviously the the
features on this little Wayne 21 Savage
James Blake
[ __ ] wild yeah
um also [ __ ] huge in the Caucasian
world the mountains of caucasia they
love James break amazing
um baby Tate's on the project
um boss you got the CEO rapping
someone hits play on this what's the
first song like let's say I can only
listen to one song
what would be your your choice like yo
you gotta go this is the one record on
here that you should go straight to if
you can only listen to one
uh brother name it's called brother now
okay featuring dirt
okay yeah it's crazy fire yeah we got
dark and like a you know how he you know
what I'm saying we got him and brought
him in my world you got Dirk like really
it ain't like and it's it's just it's my
world you know what I'm saying so it
could be a bunch of different things
could be melodic it would be like some
rap [ __ ] yeah you like some turn [ __ ]
but I just did something I ain't I ain't
think a lot of people would expect and
he went so crazy bro like
spoke about [ __ ] you know I'm saying
personal [ __ ] and it just kind of moved
me I'm like oh you really like the voice
that's what really everything you say
was and that's what they say